so how did you vote on monday and why
i with regret voted that i didn't have
confidence in in boris i made my
position clear way back in january that
i thought his position had become
untenable i don't think anything has
happened since then to change that view
probably the the reverse so without
making a fuss about it without leaving
lots of interviews and writing articles
about it
i said to my constituents who asked that
i would vote that i had no confidence
with regret the vote happened the vote
went the other way we accept that vote
and move on it's interesting as you say
you know you haven't done much media
around it you you made your position
clear um you say you want to move on um
does that mean you're ready to just draw
a line under it you want boris to borrow
johnson to lead the party into the next
election well
the problem is i don't think this is
going to end it um we've we've had a
clear vote and we must abide by the uh
the rules i absolutely respect that that
result the prime minister remains the
prime minister and the leader of the the
conservative party
but that's not ended it this has gone on
for over six months i can't think of any
other
problem that has overhung a prime
minister or a government and you're
talking about that
the whole party only this started way
before um christmas if you uh if you
remember we've still got the privileged
committee report to come out at some
stage we've still got the report into
the whole handling of uh kovid uh and
you know various other things are still
going to come out over the next few
weeks what's going to happen with kier's
stamina if kerastalma were to be given a
fixed penalty notice it makes the
president's position look a bit uh
doubtful as well so i don't think i fear
this isn't going to draw a line under it
so i think prime minister's got a big
job of work to show that he's back at
the helm
he needs to absolutely rally around the
party and build a unified party have
some changes in the in the cabinet
rather fewer people saying yes of course
boris and a few more saying are you nuts
prime minister would be helpful
um if he can do that he might just start
to win back the confidence but there's a
big question mark over there so you'd
like to see a reshuffle effectively with
people who are prepared to stand up to
him a bit more i i think we need to have
a cabinet as we've had before if you go
back to mrs thatcher's time she didn't
uh surround herself with yes men and
women or aren't any women it was people
that she fundamentally disagreed with
but would take them on people who would
say to her are you sure that's what you
want to do actually i think you're wrong
and she would say well i think i'm right
and this is why we need more of that
sort of debate in in cabinet we need far
more backbenchers there's huge talent on
the back benches who are not playing any
parting government at the at the moment
who have got a lot to offer so i think
boris has got to absolutely extend the
hand of friendship and be much more
inclusive to many more people in the
party where there is a lot of talent
that's not being used is there any names
that you would give us for examples of
those kind of no but no no because then
you'll start getting into um arguments
out why him and not her or whatever um i
think backbenchers feel a bit neglected
and i think the clear-up that happened
in number 10 had to happen but it hasn't
gone um far enough we need to be
talked to a lot more we need to be
consulted about policy um a lot more and
we don't need this problem where we're
marched up to the top of the hill to
defend things which are
a bit tricky indefensible some would say
some would say indefensible only for 24
hours later number 10 to do a complete
u-turn and we marched all the way down
again these are the sorts of things that
undermined confidence in even david
cameron and theresa may um previously so
we've got a huge challenge facing us the
country's got a huge challenge with the
cost of living that crisis with the
continuing issues around ukraine and
lots of other other things we need
absolutely to be focused on that and
delivering for the people not having
debates amongst ourselves about whether
our leader is up to being leader or not
are there policy changes that you would
like to see as well well i don't think
this is large about policies if you look
at previous prime ministers that were
got rid of
poll tax mrs thatcher started the the
slide there
this hasn't been about policy
i'm afraid it's been about
the way the prime minister has
personally handled what started as a
party gate and for me it was never about
how many glasses of warm chardonnay were
coffeed in downing street or sausage
rolls eaten it was about the way it was
handled um and that then became the
issue rather than the so-called parties
them that themselves and by the way it
was handled do you mean um lack of
contrition or or not really accepting
but i think a lot of contrition and i
think as one of your panelists actually
said earlier if he at the beginning had
actually owned it and said
actually i think we've we might have um
committed some offenses here actually i
didn't realize but in retrospect um i
think we shouldn't have done it this way
and so we need to investigate if we've
actually committed any
crimes um at all and absolutely owned it
from the start i think he put his hands
up rather than trying to say no no
nothing went wrong there were no parties
oh there were parties but they're all
within the rules and oh but i wasn't at
any of these parties but then actually i
might have been a party and that just
the credibility just just drifted that
was the problem so getting back that
that confidence of people
that his integrity is in uh intact uh
and that he's capable of carrying on
with this job is going to be a big big
challenge but people want to see a prime
minister and the government getting on
with the job of the challenges facing
everybody in their everyday lives which
aren't considerable i just wonder what
you make of the prime minister's
reaction to the confidence vote he's
described it as a very good result and
decisive victory do you think he gets it
well he clearly wasn't i mean the margin
was much tighter than most people had
expected and certainly he had had wanted
and again i think he needs to own that i
think he needs to say look okay we have
got a problem which is why i think he
needs to bring people inside the tent
who have opposed him in some cases uh
candidates who stood against him who
frankly should have been in the cabinet
right from the
from the start to try and get unity
together again and get those people
firing all cylinders at the jobs that
all those cabinet ministers need to be
doing in a government that's delivering
for the people
i'm quite intrigued as to
whether or not some of the rebels are
likely to have another go
according to the current rules of the
1922 committee the prime minister now
can't be challenged for a year but of
course those rules can be changed
is that an active discussion
no and i think what's different about
this there's a really interesting piece
in the times by william hague yesterday
about
when there are plots to get rid of um of
leaders this wasn't an organized one
where there was a clear alternative
contender this was quite a few people
who were a bit discontented you know
like like me and others thinking
actually we've got to do better than
this there wasn't so some organized
campaign i think a few people like to
claim that they were running organized
campaign it didn't actually um happen
like that the rules are the rules we've
had a result under the rules that result
stands it doesn't look good if within
days of that result you tried to start
changing the rules so i'm not really
interested in that
if the prime minister absolutely
realizes that his position
continues to be untenable as some people
have said and i said back in in january
then it's for him to make the decision
to resign until there could possibly be
a challenge a year out we're getting
closer to an election
people don't elect parties that are
divided we need a strong clear leader
with strong leadership with a good solid
cabinet and ministers firing on all
cylinders that's his challenge in the
next few weeks if he's to stand any
chance of going to next election as the
leader of the conservative party and
prime minister what do you think his
chances are of going into that election
i i honestly don't know it's really
difficult to uh to tell because all
sorts of things have happened in the
last few months that have come out of
come out of nowhere
um
and i think if there are more party gate
type
mishaps to put it mildly
um then his position becomes more
untenable you know the trouble is this
time many of us have people writing just
saying that
the behavior that promises has been
absolutely disgraceful but they've said
that about the last conservative prime
minister or anything the conservative
government does there have been quite a
few
actual conservatives who said look i've
voted conservative all my life and i
know they're conservative as my
constituency and i can't do so
absolutely so he's got to be able to win
those people back
to stand a fighting chance of being a
successful leader to win the next
election for us and the jury is out on
on that but he's the leader we've
reelected
him as the leader we need to get on with
the job of him as prime minister by
government that's doing stuff that's
outside of westminster not looking on
ourselves